this morning a medical examiner is
working to determine how an American
Airlines copilot died at the controls
the flight from Dallas to Albuquerque
made an emergency landing on Wednesday
afternoon this is the second American
Airlines pilot to die on board an
aircraft in the last two years Kris Van
Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington DC Chris good morning
good morning this is part of why there
are always two pilots in the cockpit of
a commercial airliner the FAA says
deaths like this are exceptionally rare
but at least seven airline pilots have
died in flight in the last 23 years one
passenger who was on this flight says
the captain is a hero for handling such
a scary situation so calmly American
Airlines flight 13 53 with 136
passengers and six crew was about to
land when the captain called for help so
America 13:53
yeah we've got an issue with one of the
pilots of declare emergency like to have
the medical crew meet us I'm landing the
Boeing 737 from Dallas touched down
safely at Albuquerque's airport but the
copilot 58 year-old William Mike Grubbs
died you would have to very quickly
control your body's own natural very
human response to this sudden emergency
miracle on the Hudson captain Sully
Sullenberger is a CBS News aviation and
safety expert maintaining control of the
airplane of the situation and yourself
throughout is the hallmark of a
professional in cases like this in a
letter to employees American CEO Doug
Parker wrote first officer Grubbs was on
approach when he fell ill despite heroic
efforts to revive him Mike passed away
there are high standards we must have to
meet in terms of our physical and mental
capabilities to be able to fly medical
emergency
captain is incapacitated in 2015 another
American Airlines pilot died from
natural causes while at the controls of
a flight from Phoenix to Boston we were
all shocked and like wow didn't know
them but put our life in his hands and
that was Shaun
pilots at starting at age 35 receive an
EKG with their annual physical once
they're over 40 they get that physical
twice a year Dale thank you very much
Chris